so that was kind of like a breaking
point for me in my life and I promised
myself that I was going to do something
bigger that year I ended up finishing
the year at 750 000 in Revenue Jordan
Welch has tried practically every way to
make money online until eventually he
struck it big and today his business
brings in over 300 000 a month at 25
years old so tune in to hear his
incredible life story the worst and the
most profitable side hustles that you
can start right now and the best ways
that you can start earning a lot more
money on this episode of hit the like
button and subscribe if you haven't done
that already helps out tremendously and
now with that said let's get to the
podcast welcome back to the iced coffee
hour my name is Jordan Welch and so far
this podcast has made
386 thousand dollars wow very close so
that's incredible it's been a while
since you've done this where are we at I
didn't even know so for the last three
years because we started I think in in
May of 2020 made 400
772.50 wow so that was incredibly close
because we haven't said this number in a
while yeah in the podcast so good job
you know that's what I do I know AdSense
a little bit thank you so much for
coming on the ice coffee hour this means
a lot you just mentioned I had no idea
you came to Las Vegas for the show yeah
absolutely this is one of my favorite
shows I watch a lot of episodes this is
like a weird like fourth wall break
moment and I'm looking at you guys and
I'm at the table so we're here thank you
I think Jordan and I have a picture
together like five years ago maybe even
six years ago yeah we met Santa Monica
at the Santa Monica Pier you're kidding
no did you see him did he see you who
recognized who here no no it wasn't
through that it was through uh Vincent
right yeah one of my best friends Vince
um he hosted like a dinner and Graham
was there and at the time how many
subscribers did you have do you remember
maybe like 200k 300K I don't think it
was much yeah so I was definitely one of
those subscribers and I was really
excited to meet Graham and we hung out
and you treated me with nothing but
respect man like for real and we end up
meeting up a couple more times in the
future you came to the Mastermind that
me and Vince hosted over in Los Feliz
and since then you've always been like a
mentor and a good friend to me so that's
cool yeah man glad I wasn't an apple
imagine that imagine I was just like who
are you
nah you're cool man so yeah before we
get into it I wanted to give you a gift
actually oh gosh you know it's nothing
crazy right but
um I know you are a lover of music and a
lover of coffee so yesterday I saw this
and I said Graham has to have this
what is this
you're always good with the gifts I've
noticed in a lot of your videos
gifts I don't know oh my God I don't
know if you'll like it but oh that is
cool that is really cool dude that is
awesome that is awesome yes thank you
man I think you'll be proud because it's
a very affordable gift you know I did I
appreciate that you know so yeah very
thoughtful got you man I really gotcha
thank you so much iced coffee hour we
had to do it so what a gracious guest
sorry Jack I I got nothing don't no just
you being here is by far enough all
right I appreciate it yeah so just to
come on the iced coffee hour you've done
some fantastic things okay over the past
couple of years we're excited to talk
about it you added business that you
sold and now you're blowing up on
YouTube talking with a bunch of
billionaires and like uber successful
people asking about what sets them apart
from the average person yeah I would say
so that's kind of my path the path so
far yeah plan to deviate well right now
I'm really focused on YouTube and I'm
having a lot of fun with it I get to
travel I get to make videos I get to
meet cool people and I'm making okay
money doing it as well I also have a
software business called viral Vault
it's like a product research software so
that's like my two focuses right now
yeah so when did the entrepreneurial
Spirit start in you was that it was it
at a young age have you always had this
no I don't think it started like at a
super super young age growing up I
didn't know any entrepreneurs my mom
grew up by just me and her like my dad
he wasn't really around so my mom worked
a job worked hard waking up six in the
morning taking me to school getting us
ready coming back home 6 p.m cooking
dinner just to make like eighteen five a
year you know and that's what I saw and
that's what I saw as hard work and when
I was around I would say like eight
years old we had put our house into
foreclosure so this house that we had
worked all these years to get into we
lost the house and I remember seeing the
pain in my mom's heart and my sister and
everybody and I actually had to leave my
mom at that time I had to go move to a
completely different city to live with
my stepdad and I think it was around
that time in my life that like I knew
like I didn't want to work a job like I
wanted to like do something different in
the world because I saw that if I work a
job that's what I'm going to get you
know if I worked so hard that's what I'm
going to get so I think that's where it
started when I was like 10. what was she
doing for eighteen five hours desk like
admin like you know just the the hard
work you know answering the phone
setting appointments like an assistant
you know gosh yeah what year was that
that you lost the house to foreclosure
was that during like the the housing
crisis it was around that time I
couldn't tell you the exact year because
I was so young yeah but again I was
around like eight or nine years old so I
was I was young and the memories are
super blurry from back then but I just
remember being so sad the day that I had
to leave my mom like I I yeah I was like
crying the whole car ride to my
stepdad's house so I think you know that
pain like you guys all have pain right I
feel like that kind of like ignites
something inside of some a kid to want
to go on and be successful you could do
that or it can do the exact opposite
yeah it just like makes you resent the
world and you're like okay like I want
to lash back and then go down the other
route so Props to you for using that as
like a silver lining and like using that
as a driving force for the positive yeah
I mean after that I kind of went on this
whole path of like how can I make money
without getting a job right so I start
seeing all these kids on YouTube that
were making money so I said okay let me
get this camera that my stepdad has and
just film some little videos of me and
my friends not trying to make money out
of it just trying to do something
different and we just started posting a
bunch of videos all throughout Middle
School I was doing basketball videos and
comedy skits and any video idea you
could think of I tried to create it you
know and then I went to high school and
I started a clothing brand I just
learned how to do Photoshop and I would
design these little t-shirts and and go
to a local screen printer and try to
sell them to my friends I tried to make
money through video editing I mean man
any like hustle you could think of in my
young years I tried a lot of them what
made the most money from that like what
was the most successful I would say the
way I made my first thousand dollars
back then which I thought was a million
was from reselling sneakers really so I
made pretty good money back then I would
camp out for shoes I would get the new
releases I would flip them and then I
would go on Facebook groups and I would
find shoes that people were selling for
a bargain order them take nicer photos
and sell them for a profit the game has
changed it a lot it's not something I
would do today but that's how I made my
first thousand I even made a monopoly in
my city actually in the sneaker Market
how do you do that I created a Facebook
group specifically for buying and
selling and trading shoes and because I
created the group I kind of positioned
myself as like the sneaker plug so I
basically was getting shoes from other
people and then I would post them in my
group and I would sell them for a pretty
good profit and I used that money to
actually host a conference like a
sneaker trading convention and that's
kind of like my roots in business like
when I was young I like 16 14 15. those
are the things that I was doing to get
my feet wet into this game but nothing
made me more money than my friends that
were working at Wendy's and and the
grocery store you know I was still broke
I was still Broker Than all those guys
so what is camping outside of a sneaker
thing as a young kid look like uh just
just me and my friend like just sitting
out there laughing hanging out meeting
other people it actually wasn't bad like
I so you had the dates that the shoes
would be released uh and then what time
would the store open usually it would
open like in the morning so we would
stay there like show up super like late
in the middle of the night and then be
the first ones to go through the door I
only did this a couple times though the
way that I really made the money was
from having the group right because then
I could buy shoes from anywhere what
would you look for in shoes like how do
you know what's going to resell at a
higher price uh just like how I am with
YouTube now and any business I've ever
been to I just became obsessed with it
you know just like how you are with real
estate like after a certain point in
time you know what shoes people want you
know when something has room for you to
improve on it maybe some better photos
but yeah I never made a bunch of money
with shoes that was just how I got
started you know then what did you do
with that thousand dollars yeah so
that's what I use to host the Sneaker
Convention and this was like my big
break as an entrepreneur so I was 16
years old I took this money and I rented
out the largest Convention Center in my
hometown in Fort Myers Florida and this
is a gigantic place I went there with my
mom and they didn't even think I was
serious when I said I wanted to rent it
out but she was like no he's really
wants to do it so we rented it out I
promoted this thing everywhere flyers on
my Facebook group on school I would put
stickers everywhere I got in trouble for
that and we had a couple hundred people
show up that day I remember I pulled up
that morning there was like a line
outside the door a couple hundred yeah
we had like 250 people there and it was
all paid like everybody paid for their
tickets so I'm pulling up like like okay
like we're getting paid how much are
tickets
um tickets was like 20 and then we sold
a VIP table so um for a hundred dollars
you could set up a table and put your
shoes on the table so people walking by
could see your collection we sold all of
our tables and all of our tickets but
the the sad truth is that when
everything was said and done when I
counted all my money up and I paid for
all these little expenditures that I had
accrued I didn't make any profit I
actually like lost a little bit of money
on this whole thing and it was kind of
like um another moment of pain in my
career because I put all this effort in
all this money had saved up into this
thing and it flopped you know how did
you even know to like structure it where
you're setting up tables where you're 16
years old charging for admission rent
out like where did that
I I don't think the guy Graham wouldn't
even do it today I mean he couldn't do
that yeah that's thinking big you
definitely could uh I just copied it
from somebody else like I just looked at
where the biggest sneaker events doing
in the world let me just go ahead and do
my own twist on that the only thing that
I was adding to the table was that they
didn't have that in my city so let me
just copy the formula of what's already
working and apply it to this untapped
Market which I feel like is what I've
done my whole career that's what I've
done with e-commerce that's what I've
done with YouTube like I'm a firm
believer in this idea that like nothing
is 100 original like we we find
inspiration from things we add our own
unique touch to it and that's how
creativity is formed you know you know
what that's actually a really
interesting point it kind of segues
perfectly with our sponsor Auto DS
because chances are if you're watching
this podcast right now you're interested
in side hustles and also you're
interested in making money so back in
the day I actually had a drop shipping
store it completely failed because I
couldn't really find a winning product
and also dealing with long delivery
times was a huge pain in the butt if
you've tried a Drop Shipping Store
before you know that trying a bunch of
different plugins and looking for ways
to optimize is incredibly challenging
and it usually just ends up making
things just as complicated as when you
started plus I didn't end up getting the
sales I was looking for and in hindsight
autods would have helped me a ton Auto
DS helps you stand out from the crowd
and has millions of products from
reputable suppliers you could search
filter and narrow down products to help
you find the perfect item for your sales
Journey Auto DS also has a winning
products feature which provides you with
hand-picked products complete with
Advanced analytics insights and revenue
projections additionally they offer a
tick tock spy that helps you locate the
best performing products and spot Trends
early on they also have an academy
section where you can access full
Shopify and other platform courses for
free I also really like that they had
built-in automation tools that
eventually could take a bit more of a
hands-off approach so don't miss out and
check out autods.com ich to get a 30 day
free try again that's autods.com ich to
start optimizing your Drop Shipping
business today so how do you think that
shaped you then by kind of breaking even
on a thousand dollars I think it just
hurt me in that moment but it taught me
an important lesson and that you have to
take L's in this world of business to
actually move forward but it hurt me so
bad that I quit doing business I was 16
at the time and for the next two years I
didn't start any other businesses I was
just messing around doing YouTube videos
like gaming and short films and I would
do film festivals for my school
um I was playing basketball I was just
being a high school kid I never went and
worked a job so I didn't have money like
my friend so I would walk to school
every single day and by the time I was
18 my mom was like all right Mr
businessman you ain't got no money you
ain't got a car you're graduating high
school what are you gonna do and I was
like well I'm not really sure so she
actually got me a job and me and her had
arguments because I was always like I
never want to work a job I never want to
have a job I was really firm on that but
one day she's like you got a job now and
I had to go actually to the job so that
was kind of like a breaking point for me
in my life as stupid as that sounds I
have this image of myself that that's
not something I wanted to do so I went
to work as a busboy had like this super
nice restaurant and my job lasted for
one week why did it only last we can't
leave us hanging like that well it's
like one week I worked as a busboy for
nearly two years man watch back thank
you yeah we did a weird job it's a hard
job but that's not why I left it's just
because I knew in the back of my mind
that I had made money from all these
other things that I had so much bigger
potential and I said if I stick with
this it's going to keep me locked in
because I was making good money
um but like around my fifth day of work
in there I had this embarrassing thing
happened to me I was carrying like a
tray of wine glasses and I tried to like
open the door with my shoulder and I
just dropped all of them and everybody
in the restaurant looks at me and it
felt like the music stopped and
everything kind of slowed down and yeah
man I just remember getting a car that
day I had this uniform on which I spent
my last dollars to get the uniform by
the way wearing the shoes and I'm just
like looking at myself like what
happened like you were supposed to be
the young successful business guy and
now you're here in this car not even my
car all dirty like so I never went back
to the job that day and I promised
myself that I was going to do something
bigger
um but I just didn't know what so you
just left without telling them or you
just like stopped showing up I just told
the guy I was like look like I don't
know if I'm gonna keep working here he's
like okay no problem he had no problem
after you lost all the money on the
glasses like written termination just
like all right then if we don't see you
tomorrow it was kind of like a friend
like my mom got the job to her friend so
you know and I wasn't clearly the best
employees yeah was your mom pissed nah
she was cool my mom's actually always
been like a huge supporter of me
especially in this whole business thing
yeah so she understood it but she's like
you gotta do something you can't just
sit on my couch and try to start a
little online business you got to do
something so I end up going to college
for a year
um and during that year I worked really
hard trying to be a good student and
stuff like that and I ended the year
with like perfect GPA for 4.0 and I was
like that was the biggest waste of time
I've ever done on anything in my life
like I would study all night do my
homework show up to class early massive
waste of time so during that summer I
had money I had a little bit of money
from a refund check because I did
student loans to go to college I had
like two thousand dollars and I said I'm
gonna use this money and I'm gonna flip
this money and this is going to be the
thing that sets me on the right path and
I just spent that next three months of
Summer working every single day on
starting an online business I actually
started an e-commerce business and yeah
that was that was a crazy summer how do
you pick e-commerce I did a bunch of
research on different business models
right like I looked at marketing agency
I looked at like actual physical labor
businesses like car detailing but
e-commerce stuck out to me because I
knew how to edit videos I knew how to
make websites I had learned about
marketing from flipping the shoes and
from promoting the events so I was like
I could do this business and I kept
seeing people that were like 20 years
old or like 18 years old that were
actually making money from this like I
was talking with them and I was saying
okay if these guys can do it I know I
can make this happen too so I just
picked that path and I didn't have a
plan B and I just put all of my money
into this thing I ran out of the the two
thousand dollars very quickly from
trying to learn how to run Facebook ads
it goes away quick it's expensive yeah
it goes away quick
um so then I just started scraping up
money anyway I could I sold all the
stuff I had ran out of that money but I
was making progress right I would get
like a hundred dollars a day in sales
200 a day in sales and then there was
one day where I had 500 A Day sales
um and I was like this is the business I
remember showing my mom she didn't
believe me so that was like some fake
thing or something like that
um so I had a problem though with stripe
and with Shopify maybe you guys are
familiar but they like hold your money
and I didn't have any money to continue
running this business because they were
holding like 40 of the money that I had
so again I'm at zero but I have this
business that's making like 500 a day
um so I went to one of my closest
friends and I said look bro he had no
money he worked at Best Buy I said look
if you could just let me borrow 500 I'm
telling you I got something crazy here
he's like oh yeah yeah sure no problem
he gave me the 500 and no joke that
money is what I use to scale and have my
first product that made me ten thousand
dollars a month in profit and from that
moment I never looked back on the
e-commerce game like that year I ended
up finishing the year at 750 000 in
Revenue 750 Grand in Revenue what were
you selling
um so back then I had a general store so
it's like wait when was this well it was
2017. okay so I had a general store so I
don't recommend this method at all
anymore but back then I was what was hot
you have a store selling any and
everything you know from home goods to
gadgets to Beauty to tools what I was
selling that made me that much money in
the first year I was selling like a
sandblasting gun so you could remove
rust from cars and other things I was
selling this like portable lunchbox
container for like moms to go to work I
had sold like a Legend of Zelda Ocarina
I had a whole variety of products that I
was making money with but the
sandblaster was a big one we made a
bunch of money off so how did the
business model work on that did they
place an order through you and then you
go to someone else and place the order
with them and then they ship it to the
customer directly yeah it's good old
Drop Shipping everybody that's following
this show knows about Drop Shipping so
you know is there's there's some
negative press about drop streaming
whatever but it changed my life and that
was the business that allowed me to drop
out of college and focus full time on
this entrepreneurship thing how much
were you making profit on that that
first year in December we had a month
where I did around 50 000 in profit and
that was the first time I remember
looking at my bank account I was like
wait I like have a little bit little
money now you know and I finished that
year of 2017 with almost a hundred
thousand dollars to my name and I had
started that year like zero like I had I
had nothing I was in debt because I had
the student loans so that was a huge
transformational year for me but it kind
of came crashing down after that in the
next couple years why Facebook ads no
not Facebook ads it's my own ego got the
best of me
um so in in the end of 2017 a lot of my
friends and my family members were
asking me like what are you doing like
how are you making this money because I
would show on Instagram certain things
that I was doing you'd flaunt a little
bit of your money on Instagram a little
bit but I wasn't like super like oh look
at me I was just showing people because
I was so proud of what I had built like
I would show my store and the sales I
was doing
screenshots of how much money you were
making yeah exactly I was like this
business has finally working I had no
followers like I had like it's like your
friends and your family yeah like 500
followers so my friends were asking me
like what is this so if you go to my
channel and look on YouTube like I
posted my first video and the video is
just showing people hey guys uh this is
my first video on YouTube I just want to
show you guys how I'm making money so I
broke down the whole business model and
exactly what I was doing and I started
posting videos over the next like three
months and I got like a thousand
subscribers and people started reaching
out to me for like coaching and they
want to get Consulting so I started
doing that as well and in 2018
I focused heavily on coaching because it
felt more profitable for me it felt like
it was a better use of my time and I let
the Drop Shipping thing kind of slip
away I also moved to Los Angeles in 2018
that was I think the year that we
probably yeah um so I was making decent
money from coaching but my drop stream
business was going like this the
dropshipping business was the thing that
got me to where I was today
um but it was still a general store did
you ever like change that I never had
turned it into a brand which is what I
did later in the last couple years of my
life which was the thing I wish I did
years ago but with the General Store the
problem is the product is hot and then
it kind of dies off and because you
didn't build a brand you don't have any
type of thing well also you have nothing
that differentiates you from selling
that product as well as all the other
people and if you're talking to other
people online saying this is the product
I'm selling or whatever or this is how I
create a store it's kind of like
incentivizing them to do exactly what
you're doing and then there's nothing
that sets you apart from them exactly
yeah I mean and then in 2018 I just I I
spent all the money that I made long
story short right I moved to LA I got
this stupid fancy apartment in downtown
paying like 3 500 a month in rent I
leased a car that I didn't even really
like that much just to kind of fit in
what was the car a Lexus IS300 it was
nice but it wasn't like I'm thinking
you're about to see like a G-Wagon or
something nah nah but like she you know
it just was I didn't even like lexuses I
just wanted to have like a nice car you
know I I picked up bad habits like I
started smoking and stuff like that I
started drinking more and I just started
spending money and as a result by the
end of 2018 I had a lot less money I had
like twenty thousand dollars to my name
and my expenses were like ten thousand
dollars and my drop for me store was
done out of there so I was really
starting to panic at that point and
that's what led me to really focusing on
YouTube again and starting another
business which is actually the business
I still run to this day but you sold
also you had another e-commerce store in
between there right that you built up
afterwards so after all of that
there's a little Gap in between it yeah
and I'll fill it in for you real quick
but I did sell my business last year
yeah but there's a gap in between it so
um in 2019 and 2020 I was trying to get
my software business off the ground but
little did I know software is a very
expensive industry to get into and I was
spending the last of all the money I had
to keep my life in LA and to build this
software company and it got so bad that
I had to get lines of credit from Wells
Fargo I maxed out my American Express to
the point where they like charged off
all my accounts and I was like just
miserable living in Los Angeles and
um at the end of 2019 I was like
horribly broke like I had zero dollars
in my bank account I think I had like
two bucks I had all this debt accrued
and my business was making no money so I
said I gotta leave la like I can't keep
doing this so I ended up moving back to
my mom's house
um at that point
stacked up debt no money the Drop
Shipping business done my software
business not making any money I was like
I need to start something fresh so let
me go back to my roots I'm at my mom's
house I'm back on my mom's couch I'm
back to zero let me start with the thing
that got me here today so I started
doing e-commerce again but this time
with all that experience I had accrued
over the years and I cut out the bad
habits I had so I quit smoking I stopped
drinking I started eating better and
within the first 30 days of moving back
to my mom's house I had built a Shopify
store that was doing over ten thousand
dollars a month in profit like that and
I and I started documenting it again on
YouTube so it's all there like all this
is yeah what were you selling again how
do you find a winning product like that
okay so in this case right
I found this product out of necessity so
when I moved back to my mom's house I
was sleeping in my little brother's room
and he kind of snores loud at night so I
went on Amazon and I saw this product it
was like a headband with headphones
inside of it so you could like sleep
comfortably and block out noises and I
was like this thing is genius and then I
saw on Facebook ads somebody was running
this product and they had like millions
of views but the ad was horrible so I
said as long as I can make a better
advertisement than this and a better
looking store I could capitalize on this
people want it it's clearly selling I
want it and that's what I did and the
way to find a winning product is just
looking at something that adds value to
people's lives and also looking at
something that is already going viral
and already succeeding and just asking
yourself how can you add your own unique
touch to it that's how I found that
product so I feel like every single time
I hear from somebody who does Drop
Shipping like I hear from you I hear
from Bia heza all these other like
YouTubers they're like this is the
easiest way to make 10 care month or to
make six figures in a year if you're a
young like unskilled person would you
agree with that you think Drop Shipping
is the way and it still is the way
um well it's not easy
it's definitely not easy
um if I was looking for an easy way to
make money I would probably just go work
a fast food restaurant or something like
that if you want to really build a
business it's one of the better options
out there for sure especially if you
have an inkling to like creating content
and learning how to build websites but
for some people man just learning how to
do sales will like get you off the
ground and actually get some money in
your pocket like I stand for
dropshipping because it changed my life
but I'm not going to be the one that's
like everybody needs to start a Drop
Shipping Store because I mean over the
thousands and thousands of people I've
talked to over the years I've learned
that it's not for everybody you know
like some of these people are way older
they don't know how to build a website
they don't want to learn how to edit
videos so why do you have to edit videos
if you're doing Drop Shipping well it's
really content based right because
nobody knows your brand and nobody ever
heard of you before so you have to be
able to make content that attracts
people to come and purchase your item
it's so heavily based on the content
actually a lot of people think it's like
a winning product or a magical website
design but if you know how to make viral
content it you can crush it with Drop
Shipping you know that's really one of
the most important skills but would you
say it's the easiest way to make a
hundred thousand a year because I get
making money yeah to take any job that's
an easy way to make money but like what
about a hundred thousand a year the
easiest way no but if you have the right
skill set and you're ready to focus and
learn over the next six to 12 months I
say it's worth it I know how it changed
my life and then I've impacted thousands
of people that I reach out to or have
reached out to me personally so I know
that it works and I've seen it work
countless times but no it's not the
easiest way I'm sure there's easier ways
you know I think it's window washing is
the easiest way yeah probably you know
but then you got to sit out there I live
in Florida you know I'll be sweating
like crazy
um so look I would say it's the easiest
way if you're ready to learn how to
create content and build websites but if
you're like completely computer
illiterate I would never touch
dropshipping with a 10 foot pole you
know like go do sales or something what
was the most you'd made in a month from
Drop Shipping the most I ever made in a
month and revenue was like a hundred and
seventy thousand but it was really
profitable we did around like 80 000 in
profit that month
um but the most I ever made in a day was
like seventeen thousand and what product
was that it was the Sleep band The Sleep
headphones yeah the ones that I told you
about so the difference this time
compared to the last time was instead of
let's do a store with a bunch of
products let's have a store where we
have a variety of products and then when
we find one that works let's quadruple
down on that product and let's become
the number one retailer for that product
and that strategy is what allowed me to
scale this business as high as I did and
it's what allowed me to actually build
equity and sell the business and that's
the new meta for Drop Shipping correct
is like a one item businesses I always
say for beginners not to start with just
one product on the store because usually
that first product that you test is not
going to be the one that hits it's good
to have a store with a variety of
products tests see which ones perform
the best and then you take that product
and build a brand with it but yeah that
is the new meta the General Store thing
is out I would never do that yeah
because I tried Drop Shipping I did it
for a while I did for like four to five
months maybe I had a general store I did
that just by myself I don't think I got
a single sale uh but I bought like the
the domain I was running ads and
everything and then after that I did uh
what was the The Meta during the time
where I was doing it was like you have a
store that has a general idea so ours
was called the better brow shop I was
partnered with a friend and uh it was
about like a bunch of makeup and glamor
and stuff like that our main product was
an eyebrow epilator so we would try to
it like basically like cleans up your
eyebrows you'd be using it huh I'd never
use it like see if it was cool but uh
like I never used it just to order it I
swear I swear I don't use it uh no but
we we had basically like it was a bunch
of makeup and like Beauty project
products but we had like a main one that
we were pushing out and that was kind of
like the meta during the time where it
was like a jet not a general store where
selling like leaf blowers as well as you
know eyebrow stuff and like makeup but
like a general a genre yeah that's
exactly what I recommend people to do
now call it a hybrid store okay so you
have a store maybe like the Home Goods
Niche where you could sell so many
different type of products or the beauty
Niche or the outdoors Niche where like
you said it's like a genre but it still
feels like a brand and then when you
find that product that's really hitting
you could double down on that product
that's what worked for me yeah and but
how do you build something then that you
could sell why sell a business like that
if it's making money isn't it better
just keep it two questions there first
question is how do you build a product
into actually becoming a brand and I
think it really comes down to having an
actual quality product so working with
the suppliers over in China to get your
product better than whatever everybody
else is Drop Shipping and that's what I
did I literally worked with them I
changed the speakers I changed the
fabric I changed the packaging I put my
logo on everything we added extra
bonuses in there like we gave everybody
a free book or ebook with a bunch of
sounds also having a team in place so it
got to the point where I wasn't running
the ads anymore and we were running ads
on Facebook on YouTube you on Google so
essentially this business was passively
I don't really believe in the whole
passive thing but passively making me
over a thousand dollars a day in profit
the reason why I sold the business is
because last year at that time I was
really going hard on YouTube and I was
having a lot of fun doing it and I was
losing the love for this e-commerce
business even though I had a team
running it I still had to use my mental
bandwidth to keep the business going and
I didn't necessarily want to keep
focusing on that I wanted to clear my
space to focus on this thing that I
loved I've been doing YouTube since I
was literally 11 years old so it's like
if I could do that full time I'm gonna
do that so I started working with a
broker and they got me evaluation the
company they start pitching the business
to a couple people in their contacts and
it took around like four months until
maybe like six months until I actually
got the business sold that's crazy who
buys it who's out there buying these
businesses so the guy he's private but
he bought it because he had another
sleep business and he wanted to combine
it and into his own existing portfolio
and his skill set is literally by inject
Capital inject his resources and team
and just grow the business even further
so I'm not even in contact with him
anymore but he like merged it inside of
his sleep entity and how is it doing now
are you able to say or I don't really
keep up with it I haven't even checked
on it in a long time like I feel like
that's like what if he turns into like
uh tens of millions of Dollar business
he's like okay you know I don't really
know what's going on with it it's not
under the same brand name it's like it's
totally become something different now
so it's not even like my thing anymore
what did he buy for me he bought the
product that we developed which wasn't
even patented but he just wanted to have
access to that and Skip all those steps
he bought the team that we had and he
bought all this content and marketing
materials that I've accrued over the
years and access to the ad accounts as
well that's really what he was buying be
interesting to see where it is now yeah
like how it's doing how much money is
made maybe I'll do like a video
following up with this guy one day but I
don't I don't really keep in touch with
him we did the deal he kind of went away
and that was that so so you sold this
Drop Shipping website that you had yeah
and then you also had this other what
was the the other company that you're
running at the same time the software
one yeah you remember that business that
made me go broke in Los Angeles that
software business yeah well I never
forgot about it
um but it just wasn't able to stay alive
when I was at my low moment I had
um in 2020 started it back up again once
I started documenting my journey of
doing e-commerce on YouTube and as my
YouTube channel started growing around
that time
um the software started to get some life
in it as well because I was getting
views finally I was stuck at 30 000
subscribers for literally two years I
didn't grow at all for two years where
did those initial 30 000 come from so
when I moved to LA like I said I was
doing coaching and every single week I
was posting three videos on my channel
this is when I met you I was grinding on
YouTube man I was posting three videos
super Niche down about Drop Shipping
every single week I thought that was the
way to do YouTube looking back on it it
was not the way but I would get like a
thousand views of video 5 thousand views
of video and just keep grinding them out
you know so that's how I got my 30 000
subscribers and then from there like you
were saying the way I went from thirty
thousand to a hundred thousand
subscribers was by actually taking
YouTube seriously studying titles
studying thumbnails and studying how to
make a video that people actually want
to watch because before I was just
posting as many videos as I possibly
could and I was stuck at 30 000
subscribers for years some people dream
about 30 000 subscribers but I hate that
number everybody used to bother me I
used to just look at my channel and it
just wouldn't move you know
um so from doing that and just
authentically documenting my journey of
building this e-commerce business I grew
my channel past 100 000 subscribers I
was posting a video every single Friday
and I would show a live update of my
store every single week and people got
down with that because so many people on
YouTube are talking about e-commerce but
it's just like yo guys I'm gonna show
you the 10 best products to sell but I
was actually showing people live I'm
building this business and let me show
you what I'm doing every single week and
that's kind of what got my channel off
the ground down and ignited this passion
for YouTube yeah yeah we'll get more
into the YouTube success but I also
wanted to know this other software
business what is it what was the
business yeah so why'd you pick it back
up it's called viral Vault it's a
product research software for e-commerce
store owners and we also have training
and a community inside of there so if
you want to start your store it's a good
starting place and it died because I
didn't have any people that were
following me that wanted to start a
store but once I started documenting my
journey and people saw that I was really
making money with this they were like
okay let me check out his product let me
check out his software and that business
went from the gutter it was making like
zero dollars we were losing money with
payroll every single month to buy the
middle of 2021 I was doing over a
hundred thousand dollars a month with
this business like it totally flipped on
its head and this business was way more
profitable than my Drop Shipping stuff
because all I had to do was pay my
overhead of my employees but what I did
was instead of taking that money out and
using it for a lifestyle I was living in
Miami and my rent you would be happy
about this it was like 1900 dollars a
month in Miami and I would just use all
the little AdSense money I made and pay
for my rent and just keep keeping the
money inside of the software business
hiring more people building a better
product and now last month this business
did like 350 000 it was like the biggest
month we had with the business
um so it's been like this like uh
turbulent ride with the software
business but it's moving in the right
direction so let's say you're someone
that wants to start Ecom what is the
value of this software business like
from what stage of wanting to start a
store what would it provide it's totally
tailored for beginners so I personally
curate products I have a team that does
product research and then I manually go
through and review the products that I
like the best and we upload those into
our platform each product comes with
supplier information competitor data ad
copy description video ad everything
that you would need to like put it on
your store and test it we have a
training program inside of there which I
teach and I also got my friends who are
way smarter than me to help me Teach it
so we teach Tick Tock Facebook Tick Tock
organic and then I have a community to
do with coaches so it's kind of like an
all-in-one toolkit for somebody that
wants to start their own online store
and what is the fee is it a flat rate or
is it a percentage that the store
generates it's it's super cheap it's 60
bucks a month
so wait so how did you generate 350 000
on this a lot of people I have like a
million subscribers
um and people just you know like on
YouTube so I I like even drop streaming
videos that I made a year ago are still
popping up and getting views like even
to this day I still have one of the top
ranked Drop Shipping videos on YouTube
that I made like months and months ago
so people funnel in through there
um we also come up with some new
offerings like I did a one dollar
product and that was basically just a
case study of how I took my business
from xero to selling it in two years and
that thing just went crazy so I remember
that you put that in one of your videos
yeah in the My Story video and that that
day I had made like fifty thousand
dollars that day from selling a one
dollar item yeah so you got 50 000
people signing up from that yeah well we
have like upsells and stuff in there too
but yeah that was crazy I posted the
video and then like yeah it was it was a
good day so of the people that are of
the viral Vault like the the clients of
that what is the most successful story
there's so many so I just did this
subscribers Meetup I was the first time
I ever did like a public Meetup with my
subscribers literally last weekend and I
had people that flew in from all around
the world like Netherlands Canada all
parts of the United States this kid
drove nine hours just to come to the
event but the most successful person
that I can think of in recent times was
this kid that came to me at the event
and he's like bro I've been following
your videos I joined your viral Vault
program and right now last month I did
180 000 in Revenue he surpassed my
highest month in revenue and he took a
product from our platform he followed
the training and followed the systems
that I teach on YouTube and he did it
and this isn't even like a sales piece
like these are real people like they
come up to me all the time but the
Meetup was cool I got to see like a
concentrated group of people that I've
made some type of impact on and that's
like the biggest blessing in the world
to me why do you think that one guy was
so successful like what sets him apart
so I asked him a bunch of questions
because I I was curious about that as
well and I think this holds true in any
field
he stuck with it the longest and he
didn't have a plan B he knew he wanted
to do this two years ago and he stayed
with it over the course of two years and
in the first six months he lost a bunch
of money and he ran into some issues
then six months later he started to make
some money and started to learn then the
following year he finally started making
money but it's ups and downs and you
have to stay consistent throughout that
I mean I could have quit my YouTube
channel at 30 000 subscribers because it
wasn't working right so it's what I
think it is I think that's the common
trait amongst people that I see that are
super successful is that they just
stayed resilient through like the
hardest you know and why don't you just
create the stories yourselves if you're
doing basically all the work like you're
finding the product you're running the
ads you have all the expertise but
instead you're picking people and
training them like wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be more profitable if you
just created that store yourself that
this kid had the thing about training
versus building my own store is that it
actually is more profitable I'm not
gonna sit here and put up a front and be
like it's not more profitable because
with building my own store I can make
make it make me a lot of money but
considering my situation where I have
millions of views coming in a month
millions of followers it's more
profitable for me to leverage that as
opposed to just starting another Drop
Shipping Store the Drop Shipping Store
is what got my name out there and what
established me as an entrepreneur but at
this stage of my career that's what I
get the most value out of and also it is
an impact that we're making at this
company you know many people have
started their first successful business
from what we teach so for me that that
means more than me you know finding a
cool product and turning into a brand
you know maybe I'll go full circle and
start another brand in the future but at
this stage I'm not really so you're not
running any drop shipping stores at the
moment no but you're surrounding
yourself now with some really wealthy
people like that one billionaire yeah
you just interviewed how do you how do
you meet these people Well everybody's
different right but the way I met Thomas
pettyfy who's like the richest man in
Florida was a cold email I literally
just sent him an email my girlfriend did
it saying that we wanted to do a video
with him and he responded in the most
gangster way possible he said said okay
and then he sent a calendar invite with
his address and we just pulled up no way
yeah that must be the best cold email of
all time first of all how do you get his
email what do you say in the email well
she did all the work my girlfriend she
Tracked Down found his private email
sent him a nice message sharing my brand
and what I'm all about and we got the
okay and we pulled up to his house he
has a hundred million dollar uh mansion
in Palm Beach which is like the most
expensive ZIP codes in the world this
guy has a house and then he has this
gigantic lot right next to the house and
we got there there was a butler there he
shook my hand he greeted me he's like Mr
peterfee we'll see you soon please go
sit over there and five minutes later
this guy comes out treats me with
nothing but respect by the way like you
expect a billionaire to kind of be like
stuck up no total respect and we had a
great conversation we hung out with him
for like almost an hour and what what do
you think set him apart was there
anything meeting him that you noticed
that was different about a billionaire
than somebody's not a billionaire what I
would say was he moved with respect and
I know that that made him back on his
career because he has a massive team so
if he was an his team wouldn't
really be putting that work in to get
the company to billions of dollars that
was something that really stood out to
me that I wasn't expecting also the way
that he moved with his time I've never
seen anybody like that the butler told
us he was going to come out at 10 A.M
yeah he came outside no later than 10
a.m when the interview was over it
wasn't come on guys you want to come in
for a coffee you want to he was like
nice to meet you thank you guys for
coming walked inside of his house
disappeared like a ghost you know have
you heard from him since you shot this
video with him no but I heard from a lot
of people on his team and I know he saw
my video and I know he really liked it
the video about to hit a million views
yeah I loved it yeah I thought it was
really well done I stole your title oh
what meet the dude everyone everyone has
used that title now you know what the
crazy thing is it doesn't even work
anymore no use it on her own videos and
it's so saturated that we can't do it
it's not special well everyone says meet
the blank man it's the principle that I
shared before that worked me with Josh
it's like look at what's working and say
how can I add something to that you had
the 100 million but I said okay this
guy's like 300 billion so even though
it's the same it's like different in
that way you know I like the videos
where you go to different events and you
ask people what they do for a living
yeah like what was the one was it F1 I
did F1 as like a short but my favorite
videos like that I ever did I did one on
Wall Street I went to the New York Stock
Exchange I went to the Bitcoin
conference I snuck backstage and
interviewed Kevin O'Leary
um we did one at the YouTube uh vid
Summit yeah conference and yeah I like
those videos the thing about those is
like
people come to me they're like oh you're
that guy that asked me what they do for
a living I'm like well I mean not
necessarily but all right cool let's
rock with it you know yeah so I but I do
like those videos they're very fun it
sucks because they're so basic that's
what people generally remember yeah they
get so many views and they're so simple
it's just hey you know how much money
are you making what do you do for a
living yeah I let one slip I forgot my
one of my most recent videos was asking
black millionaires how they got rich and
that video is about to hit a million in
a month um which for my channel is like
a a top performer
um so we're gonna do more of those
because I do like them and they're
inspiring for people because my goal on
YouTube is to inspire right I want to
inspire people through my story and
through my business that I'm building
and also through all these other stories
that I get the opportunity to share do
you ever wonder if some of these people
are lying to you when you ask them how
much money you make do you ever get to
sit but you don't say anything I am very
like particular about the people I put
on my channel yeah and I do a disgusting
amount of research on them because if I
give somebody a platform and they come
out as a scammer and some something down
the line I'm the one that gets pinned
with that yeah so I always make sure
people are legit before I bring them on
my channel and a lot of times I'm the
guy that's going to be like yo pull up
your phone real quick Let's uh let's
show the camera what you're making and
like people in the moment might get a
little uncomfortable but they don't
realize that it makes the viewer respect
them even much more because they know
that they're legit so I do that for
people I don't mind and how about
walking on Wall Street what type of
professions would you see people having
there how much would they be making they
looked miserable out there I'm not gonna
lie I was like I don't know everybody
was just in a rush and everybody was
feel like they're wearing just the same
outfits and like I could never work over
there but most everybody was like
Bankers or the assistance of the banker
or the assistant to the assistant to the
banker like I don't know just MPC jobs
like it was like uh it was like not
really a place I would ever want to be
involved in but we did get the
opportunity to actually go inside the
stock exchange and that was cool but it
was way different than I expected get in
there there was a guy that I knew that
worked inside of there and one of my
friends knew him very well so I just
bugged the crap out of him to say I want
to do a video inside there I want to do
a video inside there and he made it
happen but that that took a huge left
turn
um like okay I'm not gonna put the guy's
name out there because I really don't
want to give him any publicity
whatsoever but he invited us inside of
there camera's rolling gave us the full
tour like talking to the camera like
everything's all good and everything's
great thanks for coming by we did a full
interview with him then I get home I
edit my video I put it out I didn't post
it but I put it on listed I sent it to
him he goes now we can't use this what
are you talking about he's like if you
guys post this video I'm gonna come
after you like his whole demeanor like
shifted like this and I was like uh I
don't understand you invited us he's
like no this video is bad because it
shows that anybody can come into Wall
Street and I was like you're talking
crazy right now so um what I did was I
was gonna scrap the whole video but I
got creative and I had my friend who's
an animator I animated the interview I
cut out this dude's face I warped his
voice
and nobody ever knows if I really went
in there or not so wow yeah I heard it's
extremely difficult to get in that's why
I was kind of surprised that you got in
because what I've heard is that you need
so much clearance and even once you're
inside you're not you're not really
supposed to take any video pictures I
think are kind of monitored I hear
they're very like tight on security
there I'll walk right in
but like it was because I was with the
guy you know for sure yeah and he was
like with somebody he was acting like
the head honcho you know but then he got
a boss yeah it sounds like he kind of
talked himself up absolutely gotten over
his head and then when it came to his
like oh crap I can't actually do this
yeah because I started the video on the
street interviewing people and I worked
my way up into the stock exchange that
was the storyline of the video so he's
like this just shows that anybody can
come into the stocks and I'm like
whatever bro so where do you where do
you take the YouTube thing well you know
continuing to share my story and
document my journey is something that
I'm really passionate about but also now
I have so many people reaching out that
want me to share their stories and give
them a platform again I'm very picky
about who I want to do that with but
there are some amazing people like I
have an interview lined up with the
richest black landlord in America
um in Miami we're going to be doing that
video soon how did you get in contact
with this person what do they do yeah
his name is Don Peebles
um he basically started out in
Washington DC uh went to school in like
the political field and and he just
worked his way up he ended up getting a
job at the tax Advisory Board in
Washington DC and from that he was able
to get in on some properties out there
and he started working his way up he
bought a property in Washington DC for
the government as for his whole story I
have to actually sit with him and talk
with him but what I know is that this
man starred in DC coming from a lower
class family worked his way up and ended
up now having a portfolio of eight
billion dollars of real estate he owns
two hotels in Miami on Miami Beach he
owns like a private country club resort
in Miami like he was loaded what I found
is that these billionaires or even
multi-multi-millionaires that are older
they love this stuff because they get to
provide inspiration to the Next
Generation I feel like when you're 90
years old and you got a bunch of money
that's all that you have left to do is
philanthropy and sharing what you've
learned with the world so you guys you
got to share the secrets of what was in
that email like what what was so good
about that email that the guy said okay
I am so curious what we included in that
email was just the fact that this is an
opportunity to inspire people and share
your story on a large platform and then
I sent my videos and also too having a
library of cool videos helps like I send
them another example of an interview and
they're like oh this is cool so you guys
you know and one thing is like I I bet
for a billionaire a lot of people
solicit his email with like I got this
business opportunity you can make a lot
of money 10 returning a month on this
and they're like okay like I have been
through this so many times I've already
been through it so many times I'm 24 and
I'm like point zero zero zero one
percent as successful as someone like
that and people solicit stuff like that
but if it's something like oh you can
share your message you can be inspiring
to young people that's a lot more
enticing than just like some sort of
business solicitation yeah that's my
whole thing on those videos I don't
pitch anything I don't promote anything
it's really just to share their story
yeah so you know so on a more personal
level can you talk about how you balance
a relationship with everything that
you're doing and traveling and yeah I
mean the relationship has actually
helped me a lot
um for me having somebody that you can
call on and be there in your corner
every single time something's going on
whether it's good or bad how has
elevated me like crazy in life because I
was single for pretty much my whole
adult life I've been together with my
girlfriend now for about a year and a
half and recently she even like started
helping me out in my business with with
certain things so really it's helped me
a lot you know how about you how do you
guys meet oh we actually met at this
restaurant I used to go to this vegan
restaurant like almost every single day
and I had seen her working in there you
know I was like okay she looked kind of
good but then one day they were actually
filming a commercial for the restaurant
yeah and they wanted me to be in the
commercial and she was filming it so we
ended up talking that day after we were
done filming and we got connected we
went on a date like that same day and
the same day I think it was the day
after all right it was like it was like
we were ready what's that line of
Interest where it's like okay like I
think you're interested in me I'm
definitely interested in you how do you
cross that to like hey let's go on a
date like a romantic date it wasn't even
like romantic I was just like let's hang
out like so then we just went for a walk
let's hang out yeah on the beach at
Sunset so so you just said like you're
talking to her right casually because
she's near you when you want to strike a
conversation and then you just say hey
like we should go hang out sometime yeah
Jack if she's into you you can do
anything you can go anywhere you want
you know you don't have to if in fact if
you do it like super fancy like it might
actually like play against your favorite
like you know well you don't want to
show too early casual you know okay like
we went to a restaurant right by my
house we sat there on like the bar and
then we just went for a little walk and
yeah it worked the thing is some of my
friends like from back home these guys
have no money they pull straight tens
and they get whatever girl they want
that's what I'm saying I don't think it
makes that big the money thing will add
some swag to you as a man it'll make you
more secure sometimes but um it's deeper
than money and girls a lot of times like
the ones that care about money are the
ones that you really don't even want and
the ones that don't care about money is
like it gives you a chance to actually
show your character you know and that's
how you really build a relationship so
you said it's deeper than that yeah
explain that like what is it it about I
feel like a woman is more attracted to
like a man's Aura of like confidence
like does he take care of himself is
this hygiene good does he have something
in life that he's like working towards
does he have good friends like the money
is like a bonus you know but it levels
you up for sure like it adds you on a
higher bracket if you're broke you're
kind of on a lower level so I I would
agree with that I think it's like
somewhat it's not I would say it's
somewhat important right like a girl
would probably take that into account if
we can't also generalize talk about
women either because it's like every
woman got their own kind of preferences
you know but of course yeah yeah of
course but I do agree I think it has to
do with your general aura or like Vibe
not to use cliche words but it's about
like okay are you a competent person can
you strike good conversation are you
confident yeah you know Alex uh
hormozion on your show he says something
that I really liked he's like the two
dichotomies of a relationship is like
the cheerleader and the person that's on
your team I think that's a good way to
look at it and those are like the two
ones that actually work like the guys
out there he's doing his thing in his
career and his woman is in his Corner
helping him out or or they're in it
together they're both working on the
business together they're both building
this thing as a unit those are the two
that I've seen work successfully that's
how my mom and my stepdad they're
married that's how they work but then on
the flip side I've seen her previous
relationships not work because the whole
dynamic was off but not to say that it
still can't work out if let's say like
the the woman in the relationship's out
on the field like in the guys the
cheerleader it just represents a very
statistically small percentage of
successful relationships yeah definitely
and what about being vegan you brought
this up earlier you met your girlfriend
at a vegan restaurant yeah both of you
guys are true vegans well I would say
like plant-based like because like my
car got leather seats and like you know
I probably buy something like shoes but
I eat plant-based like Foods only I
don't eat meat or drink what's the
reason behind that I just started to do
a bunch of research on how like all this
meat is produced in the world and it
totally changed my perspective on it and
it made it not appetizing for me anymore
and then I said okay let me try to live
without it let me try to eat a diet
without having these Foods in my system
and I felt just fine I even felt a
little bit better than I did before I
was still in the gym I was still putting
up the weights I was putting up I felt
more energy so I just stuck with it um I
haven't had meat in five years so you
made your own personal decision to do
that was there any other like influences
on you that were saying yeah you should
become vegan one of my best friends
actually at the time we were working out
together every single day and we were
broke we would always go to Chipotle
after the gym and we would get a bowl we
would split it and we would just eat the
chicken bowl every single time and we go
one time and he's like I don't want
chicken this time so what are you
talking about bro we get the same thing
every time he's like no I don't want I'm
done eating meat and I thought he was
crazy I thought he was insane but then
over the next two weeks he just starts
educating me on all these things he's
learning he started sharing all these
Resources with me and I was like we're
still working on he's still killing it
he's still even doing better than me so
that's one of the biggest influences
that led add me to doing that and he's
still plant-based to this day and he's
actually one of the healthiest and most
shredded people I know he does Jiu Jitsu
Muay Thai the man can lift crazy
um so I don't knock anybody for what
they choose to eat but this is what I
choose but why no fish I never used to
like fish I never I never ate fish
growing up my mom didn't like it so we
didn't eat it in the house so I don't
have like an appetite for it I actually
don't even I hate like like anything
that has that taste like seaweed or
anything like that I hate it the salty
kind of ocean the ocean he taste that's
like that oh man yeah I respect that I
love the fact that you made your opinion
for yourself and you just like made the
decision totally cool yeah I get a lot
of feedback from my friends you know
because I'm friends with a lot of these
entrepreneur biohacker type of cats and
they always be like oh you need to eat
grass-fed steak and drink raw milk from
the cows and like I hear you bro but
like I'm doing my thing that's fine I
think it's a big problem that everybody
is now an expert and they're just like
you gotta do this this will fix you this
will fix that and everyone's an idealog
that wants to share their ideas and try
to force their ideology on other people
I think yeah super yeah so I respect the
fact you made your decision for yourself
you're not forcing us on anybody and
you're just living your own and within
your own line I think all it is is just
eight hours of sleep don't drink don't
smoke get some exercise 30 minutes a day
I think it's that simple and drink a lot
of water drink good water too you know
that's a big change that I made in my
life over last year like drinking a lot
a lot of water and making sure the
quality of the water is on point
um that has made it what do you look for
in water I just don't drink water at the
top anymore what no Graham I hear the
tap water's better so you're on the
Olive Garden water I just get Spring
Water I buy glass bottles of spring
water they ship it to my house every
single week you still drink tap water
yeah I do Graham you're so rich no the
tap water is better quality Los Angeles
Las Vegas tap water is phenomenal the
testing that they have sponsored by the
city of Los Angeles yeah I heard the
testing that they do on water is more
strict than the testing on bottled water
I saw a study a while ago this is on
like the the top page or Reddit where
they went through and tested Waters and
they found that tap water was actually
better for you I think there are studies
that would go against that and argue
that as well for me I just feel the
difference I used to drink the every day
like out of the refrigerator like the
filter in there compared to me actually
drinking Out The Bottles most of the
time and drinking much more of it I feel
better I used to wake up super tired
every day too and that change actually
made me feel a little bit more awake
yeah I mean I agree with it too someone
switched your water I don't know man
Miami that just just think about all the
stuff that goes through those pipes and
all those systems I actually believe
that it makes a difference maybe I'm
tripping maybe it's Placebo but I've
seen a difference in my life so for the
veganism it's due to the ethics or is it
the environment what is it more
specifically it started just learning
about what it takes to produce meat and
it changed my whole perspective on it
and also understanding the impact that
that had on the environment now there's
arguments as well on the plant-based
side for farming vegetables and fruits
and how that impacts the environment but
that was what led me to starting it just
you ever watched like videos of like
animals getting like tortured in a
factory yeah yeah like you ever you ever
saw like these like boxed in factories
where the cows are like this close to
each other yeah and their heads stick
out the thing and they're getting
whipped all day yeah you ever saw how
they make milk no like it's not like a
farmer in an outfit with smiling pulling
it there's like a metal thing that they
attach to the bottom of the cow that
like yolks the bottom of their Udders
and like blood comes out of there plus
comes out of there and then they run it
through the filter and then they give
you the finished product where the guy
smiling with a cow so okay so I saw one
of those videos for milk and I stopped
drinking milk after that but I never was
like a big milk person anyway but I saw
that I stopped all together so milk is
one of the biggest scams in American
history because if you look at the
marketing campaign that they ran for
milk it was one of the biggest marketing
campaigns of all time got milk LeBron
James Michael Jordan Tiger Woods Serena
Williams if it was so good why why are
we trying to push this to everybody why
does every child from the age of six
years old get served milk in school
instead of water because they want you
to build up the habit of drinking the
milk it's not because it's so much
healthier for you to drink this every
single day I thought as a kid it was
like calcium like yo you get your good
calcium yeah build your bones build your
bones get them strong yeah think about
the quality of the school milk that
you're getting you think you're actually
getting good quality milk you're
probably getting the bottom of the
barrel lowest thing ever I used to drink
strawberry milk every single time
oh man The Nest quick I'd mix that in
that's right I used to like chocolate oh
I used to like it too but the the school
lunch that they feed kids is terrible
but that's a whole other topic yeah so
you're very into nutrition I mean I try
because that's like the final frontier
like look I know I'm gonna make money
more money in my life right but what is
it worth if by the time I'm 50 and I got
a billion dollars that I'm completely
out of shape and I can't enjoy it you
know so I I guess you could say I'm big
on nutrition I think everybody should be
you know is that your goal 50 one bill
um I don't really look at it like that I
had this big realization
um last year because I had set a goal
for myself to accomplish a certain
number of subscribers on YouTube and
right on December 31st I hit that exact
number so I said okay
what if I could have put a bigger number
on the board maybe I would have did
better so I changed my perspective this
year and it's actually been working like
way better for me to just say okay
let's just do the very best that I can
do every single day let's not put a cap
in what we think is possible and just
let's see what can happen and as a
result I mean I've had my biggest month
of subscribers I've had my biggest month
of income I feel like less of like a
shot clock pressure of like oh I gotta
hit this target by this time
um so were you investing in what are you
doing with that money so I have a lot of
my money in cash
um I have maybe only like 30 percent of
it invested I have money in a couple
stocks that I like I have a bunch of
money in index funds on the Fidelity
index funds I have Bitcoin I have
ethereum have watches I have the car
that's kind of where my money scattered
but really the majority of my money is
in cash because I still have Trauma from
when I ran out of all my money so I kind
of like sure haven't it but I realized
that that's kind of a mistake yeah
usually like keep one like for you even
like two years of expenses in cash yeah
I have like I have like many many years
of expenses in cash you got to think
logically it's like if you were to
invest it let's just say the worst stock
market crash ever you lose 60 percent of
your money how long will that
realistically last you usually crashes
like that take about four to ten years
to recover assuming from the peak so
it's like can that last you the four to
ten years well you're also continuing to
make money so like when you think of
those things logically like even the
worst case scenario yeah 10 years right
you'll still end up on top at the end
right yeah it's true I need to be a
little bit more aggressive with it and I
do kind of aggressively invest back into
my business like we spend a lot to do
videos and travel and I've never been
paid to do a video ever like I never did
an interview with somebody as a paycheck
or anything we pay for everything out of
pocket I have a big team that I work
with on YouTube and viralvault so I
guess that's probably the biggest
investment you know it's back into my
business yeah but you're right I I do
need to get rid of some of my cash
because it does nothing yeah you know
that's why I tried to do that savings
account just like to get some money
accruing because in the Chase account
just kind of dead in there the
treasuries I do have 5.2 5.3 I saw I saw
your video about each other and I bought
some on Treasury direct so yeah yeah
it's complicated to figure that out yeah
I know it wasn't so bad the horrible
website though yeah if they just made it
easier you know well they have the best
product they don't even need to optimize
it you know it it makes me think that
they don't even want people to buy these
things because they just don't make it
that like friendly like imagine someone
who's like seven years old wanting to go
figure out how to do this it's hard it
is super hard but what I just looked it
up on YouTube just like how I learned
everything in my life so YouTube
University baby I'm always watching
YouTube you know I watch my boy Grand to
of course there we go yes did you watch
my window washing video I saw the
thumbnail you're gonna watch it yeah you
got to watch it that I want to turn that
into a new series so you actually went
with somebody that does window wash
that's why I was saying like we're
talking about the easiest way to make
100 Grand a year I'm like window washing
okay I didn't know you actually went
with somebody I thought you were just
telling people no no that's why you got
to click on the video because my whole
thing is I want to do like an undercover
jobs where I go through with other
people and they teach me how to do what
they do yes and I want to focus on like
young people making really good money
and weird careers that you wouldn't
think of and window washing was one of
them so you were out there washing
windows yeah so I met this guy because
he came up to the house and a neighbor
said that he was going door to door
doing window washing and gave me his
business card I was just curious because
the guy came up and like was kind of
looking through the windows I'm like
you're trying to rob the place like I
don't know because he just like peered
Through the Windows that's kind of weird
so I looked him up on Instagram and I
see that he was 19 years old uh wife kid
and is going door-to-door window washing
windows I'm like dude like you've got to
help out this person and so I'm like hey
I'll just I just want to send you a
hundred dollars just for free no strings
attached I just want to support an
entrepreneur and like you know give a
thumbs up that yeah like keep doing that
that's great some encouragement and he
was like no I don't even want the
hundred dollars just give me like a 10
minute phone call with you and that's it
and so on the phone call he's like yeah
I really want to buy a house and I'm
like dude how much money are you making
well you know anywhere 10 20 000 a month
what washing windows at 19 years old
he's like yeah it's really good and he
walked me through his whole business I
just it sat with me for a while so I
came up with this idea I'm like how cool
would it be just to Shadow him for a day
uh and just see what happens and I did
and so my goal for the day was to make
500 washing windows and we pull up in
this area and we just start door
knocking and it's horrible and that we
did like three to five houses of just
like you know knocking on doors being
told no have you ever done door-to-door
sales before I did door-to-door like
door knocking as a real estate agent for
a while in Mar Vista hated it yeah and
so I did a week of that and I decided
I'd rather quit door knocking than have
to do this ever again so I stopped I
hated it but it was actually the first
house we knocked on was the president of
the HOA in this community and she was
not happy how did you get in here and
we're like you know we gave her a bit of
a story and she's like you can't be like
horrible and I'm like dude should we
keep going he's like nah don't worry
about it we'll just we'll just go over
here instead I like this guy so we went
over there and like the fifth house was
this uh was this older lady we just
talked to her she was so nice and she'd
like haggled this down a little bit but
we got a 250 job wow washing windows and
so he's like yeah you know we did pretty
good so far but we ended up making over
a thousand dollars that day going door
to door we started it we really started
door knocking at like 8 A.M and we
finished at like six but from an eight
to six making a thousand dollars in a
day was insane yeah that's incredible
and it just goes to show that you don't
need to start some crazy business to
make a bunch of money she didn't work
and you need to pick a skill that you
can focus on bro is obviously really
good at Windows yeah he was good at
Washington he was better with people so
he was really good at handling objection
because he would turn these situations
around like I couldn't do that they
would say oh no I'm not interested he'll
be but you know what it's a really good
price how about this how about I just
take a look around and I'll give you a
quote no I'm not really interested well
how about this it's a hundred dollars
off right now only because I did a job
down the street uh how much is it this
price and we'll throw in this for you I
don't really wanna we'll throw in this
if you say yes right now yeah and he'll
get yeses yeah it's a good way to make
money my big brother also he's kind of
like me in a way he didn't work a job
yeah he made his first money from doing
mobile detailing so same thing yeah
door-to-door going to houses saying hey
we'll clean your car it's super dirty
I'll do it check it out you pay me after
and he did this for a long time now he's
in the real estate game but he really
made his first money just from doing
mobile details yeah so that's that's the
next one that's why I was bringing that
up it's such a wholesome story but I got
a letter in the mail to the PO box box
from a high school student who says hey
I'm washing cars on the weekend I've
been saving all of my money I bought a
mobile detailing truck with all the
money that I made on weekends and I'd
like to wash your car for free as a
thank you good good and so I met him he
washed the car for free did such a good
job did such a good job and we kept in
touch and I think I did like an
Instagram shout out and then he started
cleaning Ryan pineda's car and from Ryan
he started like cleaning all these other
people's cars and now he's cleaning like
all the YouTube Cars you changed his
life and so yeah but well no he was
already doing that like you you was
doing that a lot yeah he was doing it
way before so now I want to showcase him
and go along with the day and he's like
dude show up on this day it'll be a good
day we could wash cars together I love
this series here I think it's great and
it shows people what it really looks
like to get out there and make money I
think it's probably fun for you to you
probably get bored of being in here
doing talking videos all the time yeah
it's tough for me because I look at it
from a business perspective and I'm like
where can I get the most value for my
time and we spent such a long time on
that window cleaning video like such a
long time it was a whole day of filming
Alex spent three days editing the video
we spent a whole day reviewing it and I
was exhausted like doing like that much
time but doing that one day I have to
tell you I could have made two to three
normal sit-down videos in that time yeah
because not only was it physically
exhausting mentally it was exhausting
the rejection that you get all the time
it takes a toll but talk about the
dopamine Rush when it was all said and
done and you made a thousand dollars
like it probably was higher than you
ever feeling after you finished I mean
he made the Thousand eyes I'm not taking
any money from that but it's the win of
the story you know yeah I hear you but
it's hard for me because when I look the
ad Revenue videos substantially lower
than when I make like a Federal Reserve
update video so it's like for me those
videos probably make a fifth of what I
could do just in the office so it's
tough same for me I mean when I when I
pivoted out of dropshipping videos it
started broadening it up a little bit my
CPM cut into a third yeah but I fell in
love with the videos that I was creating
I didn't really love making these
dropshipping tutorials oils as much as I
did actually being outside filming using
music that I like telling stories
editing putting things putting funny
stuff in there that I never would put in
there normally people seeing my
personality and that's when I was like
it doesn't matter if I just keep doing
this the money gonna come back around
and it has you know so that's that's
where I'm at I'd love to do one of those
a week and just do that yeah you
mentioned like staying away from things
that might like pull you down what are
those things for me it's like sleeping
super late being lazy acting like I'm
retired or something
um just eating crappy Foods playing
video games I do love video games but I
try to limit that these days you know
that's good
um alcohol I like to drink occasionally
but I I really keep that to a minimum
sure just the standard stuff the stuff
that you know in your heart you
shouldn't be doing you know but we do it
anyways how do you make sure you don't
get complacent I see where you are right
now and it's like oh I'm fine well you
know I actually tried to retire before
it was so boring like um the first time
I ever like looked at all my money and
added everything up and I had like a
million or whatever I was like okay I'm
gonna retire now just like chill out for
like a month and do nothing that was
like the most depressing month of my
life like I was bored nothing was happy
for me like the first day was cool
because I was like free and then your
brain needs something you have to have
something that you're striving towards
like you have to have some type of goal
like that's why I feel like when people
retire at like 60 and they do nothing
they like die internally you know
um so I don't get complacent because I
realize that it's boring and it's like
not fun I like creating stuff so what
happened in that month when you didn't
have that main driving factor of working
did you just have a slow regression into
like okay I'll skip the gym today I'll
eat a little bit worse today and was it
just like every day was getting worse
and worse yeah it just became alert I
just became lazy and I got bored and I
wasn't working hard I wasn't making
videos I wasn't running the business I
would check in with my team but it was
just a complete like let me just try to
step away from everything and see how
that goes hated it yeah hated it and
what's the goal now for the future like
yeah I know that we previously discussed
a billion dollars at 50 years old but
like where do you see this going in a
decade 30 years Etc I don't know I just
want to keep trying my best and do as
much as I can on a daily basis and I
think the potential for this is like
truly Limitless I never would have
thought I would have a million
subscribers right now
um just like last year in January I had
like literally 200 000 subscribers and
that took me 10 years to get that and
they go from 200 000 to a million in one
year it's kind of like a testament to
the fact that we don't know how big this
thing can actually be so for me what's
the goal is just to try to become the
best version of myself and Inspire other
people through that journey and also
travel around the world and meet cool
people like you guys and share y'all
stories with the world because there's
so many amazing people that don't have
that platform and hopefully can Inspire
the Next Generation and this this
current one as well so yeah what's your
advice for people watching I would say
people should take less advice really I
would say that you should just follow
what you know in your heart that you
should be doing because a lot of times
your intuition is kind of guiding you in
the right direction but if I was going
to give any piece of advice I would say
pick one person that really stands out
to you and somebody that you really want
to emulate and just study them because
if you try to go ahead and study every
single person in the world and try to do
what they're doing and do what they're
doing I found it's not going to work I
would rather have one Mentor that is
doing the exact thing that I want to do
and just Shadow him and learn from him
as much as I possibly could so that's
been my truth thus far I agree I think
there's like a honeymoon period of
starting a new Endeavor and you really
like it for three months and then you
hit your failure and then you try maybe
a little bit more and you hit another
failure and then you pivot but you never
get actually past the hump of like
making money being profitable and
enjoying it and same goes with the gym
it's like you kind of like that
honeymoon period and I've I've been
through this phase so many times where I
hit the gym and I love it for a month
and then I stop because I'm not seeing
progress and I go back six months later
you just gotta keep pushing through that
yeah absolutely
um and then the only other thing I would
say is that like you should not compare
yourself to me or to Graham or to Jack
because it's like I used to do that and
I sometimes still find myself doing that
the reality is we all come from
completely different backgrounds and you
should look at somebody else's success
as a testament to the fact that you can
do it too not they did it so now I can't
do it it's they did it so I can
definitely do it and maybe bigger than
they did so we should celebrate the
success of other people and we should
not look to other people with jealousy
or Envy or comparison because that is
going to hold you back so much and it
has in my life and once I started living
life and kind of like this mindset of
like yo if he's winning that's a good
thing it's possible I started becoming
way more successful so that would maybe
be another thing I would say and
generally speaking what do you think of
some of the biggest problems in the
world right now I think what we feed and
educate what we feed our children
mentally and physically is going to
become a massive problem I have a little
brother and I have nieces that are like
six and and two years old so I see what
it's like growing up as a young kid and
today going to a public school I think
that does not scale very well at all I
think we have some crazy bubbling issues
with the economy as I learned from
studying my boy Graham right here that
will come with a cost eventually even
when I was with the billionaire he told
me like this next market crash is going
to be bad he's like the some of the
stocks that you own will not be here
when you come back around you know like
what are you owning no he was saying
like this was a general this was a
general statement because you bought
pelotonics he literally he went like
this Neo he said the stocks that you own
will be worthless this man got real
serious on me like talking about it's
going to be one of the worst crashes
ever so that scares me
um and also I think the fact that we
spend so much time on social media
especially the children will scale out
pretty badly but what I found is that if
you focus on all these external factors
it only holds you down in life so if you
can focus on yourself and being the best
version of yourself that is truly the
only way that you can make an impact on
the people around you in the world so
you can't consume yourself with the news
so much I agree I think people are way
too distracted nowadays like everything
is distracting your phone Billboards
advertisements this that YouTube gurus
and like Tick Tock everything is just
distracting people pulling them away
from Solitude where they can actually
think and work through their own
problems over stimulation you know yes
absolutely yeah
oh that's why you delete tick tock yeah
and subscribe to the iced coffee Yes
except uh our Tick Tock obviously yeah
is good right we teach educate only stay
on that one now I think this type of
format of content is good for people
because it actually makes you use your
attention and not sit there and watch a
five second video you know you actually
have to listen on Clips drive a lot of
traffic good very good yeah so it's the
clips that get you in and then hopefully
you watch the whole video
those clips though yeah I've had some go
crazy I had one get 13 million views
that's like the biggest thing I've ever
posted geez yeah I had one on my second
Channel got 50 million ideas which one
would Mr Beast no uh-uh it was a random
clip I did on a video that bombed it was
Judge Vonda B clip on child support Josh
took it clipped it up posted it on Tick
Tock and I think you got like seven
million views on Tick Tock and he's like
do you gotta post on YouTube and I did
got 50 million views on YouTube that's
amazing and it's just a stupid clip on a
video that bombed and I don't know why
it did so well shorts it was just like
Hey we're gonna promote this video but I
mean it was interesting you know why
because it was so divisive the comments
was probably fighting each other yeah
you know what I think it was uh the
husband wanted child support from the
ex-wife she was making like a hundred
grand a year but because she didn't want
to pay child support she quit her job
and got a job at like 7-Eleven and then
claimed that I can't pay a child support
because I'm not making the money anymore
you would be funny on like a judge show
if you were to judge I would watch that
show I would love to judge uh like money
in relationships I can be so much fun to
have like a couple here's a money
problem let's solve it together you ever
thought about doing a series like that
on YouTube like we tried it on the
Graham Stefan show we did yeah oh man
yeah we had people call in that had
Financial issues and Graham was like the
coach between them yeah oh there were
some wild ones I like that format for
you I'd watch that especially if they
were actually there that's the thing
they were all like over the phone and
you don't quite get the grass you gotta
get the emotions of like oh man there
was one caller that I'll never forget he
called me asking if you should break up
with his girlfriend because he spends a
hundred dollars a month on her and he's
like this is what Greg was promoting
like being as Frugal as possible and
then his fans were just like oh my God
no even I was like yo that's extreme
yeah and like how often do you see her
he's like you know once a month and I'm
like
yeah he's like well we're long distance
but when she comes down I have to spend
a hundred dollars
is there anything you could do for free
he's like yeah yeah but you know we'll
spend money on that I told him he's a
little crazy it's the average girl
Stefan fan they uh you got a penny pinch
man no no but you know what I also told
him that if he's questioning a
relationship over a hundred dollars a
month yeah it's probably not gonna work
out he should probably just cut it yeah
I agree probably not you know if that's
if that's a question probably not a good
sign yeah I spend money freely on my
people I think that's the craziest thing
I spend money on is like when it comes
to my family and my girl and my friends
like we go to dinner I pay for
everything we we go
yeah
that's perfect where do you want to go
Jack it's on me man
um unless I leave my wallet in the car
then you might have to get it see I
leave my wallet in the house yeah every
single day no I could I I could learn a
lot from you though because I feel like
I don't spend like crazy but I'm
definitely not the most frugal guy you
know but I I'm not like the the craziest
either with money like I have friends in
Miami they just
very much different from the rest of the
United States yeah it's like
um
you know it's like a swinging contest
you know of everybody trying to show
that they got it and I stopped playing
that game a long time ago because I
realized that nobody actually cares
really so we had uh fresh and fit on and
they're from Miami and they explained
everything is like the watch the car the
penthouse like all those things you
gotta have in Miami and the clubs yeah
but the real big dogs the real big dogs
don't really respect those guys like
that so they're like appealing to like
the the crowd of flashiness yeah um so
it depends on what game you want to play
when I went to the Billionaire's house
you think he'd give a about what
watch I got on or what type of car I
drive no he respects my character and my
integrity and how I move as a man and
that goes for all these people that are
really successful in my network it's
only the little boys that make their
first couple hundred thousand dollars
that actually care about like a
penthouse in Miami that they're renting
you know and they share it with their
homeboy like that's it's lame to me like
after living in LA and after living in
Miami I've seen so much of this rented
fake lifestyle file that none of it
impresses me anymore like the
Lamborghini doesn't impress me anymore
the Rolex doesn't impress me when I
don't care like what are you building
how are you as a person and how do you
treat the people around you that to me
is what is impressive you know what I'm
seeing now it's getting promoted uh is
that old money thing have you seen this
oh I've seen dude okay so what's so
funny is that I was I was scrolling I
think it was Instagram and it's like old
money versus new money and it's like
shows old money is like you know no
logos on shirts and stuff like that
understated like the preppy sort of
Easter style and then it shows the new
money of just like the flashy car yeah
and for some reason I'm like how does
this get so many millions of views and I
just I keep seeing it get recommended
then be a hesitated video talking about
how he profited from a trend of right
now it's old money and that's the style
and the trend and like Abercrombie was
kind of marketing towards that so he was
like if if abercrombie's you know I'm
gonna buy calls on abercromb being gonna
make money and he did and that that
switched it for me is like oh this
is a trend right now yeah so I think
we're going towards that like
understated kind of vibe where people
aren't flashing things a little more
conservative I think we're going towards
that right now yeah you can thank uh
Andrew Tay and Iman grazi for that one
for sure they're kind of I feel like
leaders of that type of movement you
know these guys are like oh don't wear
any logos you got to be fresh and fly
you know I think they're I think they're
kind of leading that because I see I see
people that just like clone those guys
like one of one clones like the way they
dress how they act yeah absolutely you
know I could see the dressing but not so
much like the watches and the cars and
you can't clone iman's watch collection
that thing is ridiculous yeah but I'm
sick but even even Andrew Tate's watch
collection it was usually like a Richard
Mill yeah um or or something of like
he's flashy they're both flashy but in a
very tasteful way sure and that's how I
like to do it too you know I don't like
to be super flexy this is maybe the
flashiest thing that I own but other
than that you never see me wearing a
shirt with like big brands on or nothing
like that I try to keep it clean yeah
yeah so any uh other questions yeah for
us anything we can answer for you when
you look at my YouTube channel now now
that I have a million Subs you've
probably seen some of my videos I've
seen them all
damn yeah well thank you how do I
double down and take this even further
what would you do if you were me right
now I personally think most YouTube
channels have a lifespan of two to seven
years two to five years I think what
you're doing now is on The Cutting Edge
of what is good
but I worry that it's it's hard to
submit your name on that long term
Daniel Mack did a really good job at
that with cars really good and now you
can see he's expanding and he's expanded
his business a lot uh I'd find a way
that you could make this sustainable for
just like three years and how you could
be the best at it because it'll get
really saturated from the sense of a of
a repeatable style that anyone could say
this works I showcase this I do a house
tour I do an interview it's this this
formula now that's doing really well I
don't know how long it's going to do
well for I'd probably give it a year
maybe two years so I think how you could
roll with it today to make it as best as
you can for the next three to five years
yeah we'll keep doing that I feel like
the differentiator is like trying to get
the highest caliber of people that I can
that other people can't get yeah and the
actual production of the video itself so
it actually like stands out as like oh
wow like that was it that's very much
the NS approach because we were just
with Ennis yes and Ennis has kind of set
himself apart as far as the house tours
go yeah because he says he has this very
precise attention to detail he goes you
know he'll do an extra 30 hours of work
for extra point zero one percent
Improvement in the video I'm the same
way and he says that he thinks that's
what sets him apart from all of the
other competitors and the people that
you want to attract like the
billionaires or the really you know the
interesting people that you want to
highlight on your channel those are the
types of people that will notice a
difference you're not doing it for the
fans you're doing it I think it's that I
think it's difficult because that
doesn't always yield the largest
audience all the time is like that point
zero one percent like some people
appreciate that for sure but sometimes I
see the weirdest House tours just take
off because either the person behind the
camera is interesting or the house is
unique there is a really cool Airbnb the
tour was good but it was an Airbnb built
into the side of a rock that was just so
unique it was filmed well not in the
like the level of you know what what
Inez would be doing but
oh man but it got like 10 million views
on this and I'm seeing a lot like Eric
Conover is doing you know similar videos
to an S but the last thing I want to add
to this yeah is that I think the way
that I can keep doing this for a long
time is making people connected to me
yes so it's like it they they come to
the show to see me and who I'm meeting
not always just to see who the new guest
is and that is really the challenge I as
as I I look at this question you asked
me earlier what am I struggling with
that is the challenge for me now it's
like I know how to get millions of views
on YouTube consistently but now how can
I convert these people into like a real
Die Hard fan base and I have that
because when I did my Meetup and I saw
the turnout I was like damn but how can
I do it even more yeah I think sharing
more of your story and more of your
opinion I think that'll help uh like the
video that got me the most was your
story like that one video where you did
the one dollar thing at the end like
that one sticks with me and I think for
for me the one video that I built a huge
audience from who really cared about me
was uh the video why quit my nine to
five job it was like a 30 minute long
video uh but people who watch that video
all the way through like they're not
gonna forget that story yeah they might
get less views in the moment we build a
stronger connection yes yeah so I think
interweaving that within your content I
think would help a lot I will thank you
yeah thank you so you're making 350 000
a month from your
from your viral uh was it called viral
Vault viral Vault okay is it a month I
made 350 last month oh okay but
that's from variable and from YouTube oh
that's everything together yeah okay so
there's our title uh uh we'll also run
the title and thumbnail by youth that's
fine if you'd like
um so how much are you doing off YouTube
now I think last month it was like 55
000 something like that 58 000
um so it's like 50 to 70 a month in
AdSense and then you did 300 000 with
the viral Vault last month yeah and I
also it was like yeah because I have
also a Shopify affiliate that pays me
um I have like a partnership with I I
got a couple different streams of income
but those are the two main ones and how
is your time spread to all these
different Revenue drivers I really just
check on my team for viral vote and I
make sure everything's moving but the
majority of my time on a daily basis is
spent on YouTube so coming up with ideas
working on our new video that we're
filming or editing and I'm like I'm a
YouTuber right you know like I'm a
business guy but like if you ask me what
I do every single day YouTube I'm really
working on my YouTube channel see I
would say like oh you got to focus more
on viral Vault because it's the real
Revenue driver yeah of all you know your
entire production but at the same time
time YouTube is kind of funneling into
virus so it makes sense that you would
focus on YouTube even though the actual
like number Avenue reads or the ad
revenue is not going to be like super
significant relative to viral Vault yeah
when YouTube grows everything else grows
it's kind of like the the uh pulse you
know I agree with that yeah so thank you
so much for coming all the way to Vegas
and doing this but one thing that would
mean the world to me though I just have
to ask okay if you smash the like button
for the YouTube algorithm it helps out
substantially it really does as well
please a huge it makes a huge difference
I've tested now across various videos
where I really talk about just hitting
the like button it does actually make a
difference in the number of views a
video gets just hit the like button
that's it and subscribe and on top of
that all of Jordan's information will be
linked down below thank you so much for
coming on the podcast appreciate it
really means a lot and until next time
see ya yeah thank you guys if you press
the stuff